[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
unia nièce nous sommes ici aujourd'hui
pour montrer notre désaccord avec notre
gouvernement nous sommes ici aujourd'hui
pour montrer notre désaccord avec la
corruption
notre désaccord avec la restriction de
la liberté des médias pour dire à quel
point il est important que les médias
soit indépendant pour qu'une société
démocratique fonctionne et nous sommes
et semaine pour montrer notre désaccord
avec le manque de transparence de
l'utilisation des fonds publics et
autres pratiques litigieuses
nous insistons donc pour que notre
gouvernement démissionne
[Applaudissements]
ce jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens
[Musique]